Wanda and vision we are an unusual couple you
know we don't have an anniversary huh or a song
or even wedding rings well we could remedy that
and they lived happily ever after
westview is our home now i want us to fit
in we shall Wanda! Have you gotten bigger?
life moves pretty fast out in the suburbs
hiya kids auntie agnes is here and i've got
a couple of tricks up my sleeve uh let's just
take it from the top
who are you i don't know
i think something's wrong here
we just don't know what to expect
Welcome back everyone merry christmas Marvel
dropped a new wandavision trailer with a bunch
of new footage so we'll break it down there's
a bunch of easter eggs obviously i'll be doing
videos for all the episodes that's going to
start in a couple weeks so be sure to subscribe
to get all those because it's christmas we'll
also do a disney plus giveaway for memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and just let me know which new marvel phase 4
series you're most hyped up about i'll talk a
little bit about how this connects to loki in
the other series the other marvel phase 4 movies
because Wandavision is like the real first marvel
phase 4 project that they have running and it's
going to sort of set off the big marvel phase 4
trope of the multiverse that they're going
to rely on really heavily as a story device
everyone thinking about spider-man 3 and all the
spider-verse stuff with toby mcguire and andrew
garfield that it seems like it's happening
behind the scenes so hopefully marvel will
also start talking about that real soon too just
gotta wait for tom holland to leak some of that
information but the cool thing about this version
of the trailer is that marvel is just calling it
reality which is obviously a meta reference to
a couple big different avengers ideas it's a
reference to the new reality that scarlet witch
creates for them in the town of west view that's
also a bit of a west coast avengers reference
for those of you that are big classic comic book
fans there are also a lot of west coast avengers
easter eggs and references happening in some of
the other marvel phase 4 movies that are coming
up that i'll talk about when we get to those
there's a lot of avengers stuff in marvel phase
4 that's just happening on the actual west coast
of the united states reality is also a reference
to the reality stone the infinity stone because
we see the infinity stones in the trailer like
the mine stone thanos used the reality stone to
change his reality as he saw fit that's pretty
much what scarlet witch is doing in the trailer
here constantly changing their bubble dimension
of reality as she sees fit and you also remember
that when thanos was using the reality stone the
effect was this red energy that looks a lot like
the red energy that she gives off when she's using
her powers even though she got her powers from the
mind stone and usually the energy that comes out
of the mind stone is yellow like the stone itself
reality is also a reference to the alternate
realities in the multiverse big trope story device
of marvel phase four like this alternate reality
that they're living in is a tv-based dimension but
they cycle through the decades again with a whole
bunch of new scenes and more focused on bigger
easter eggs just going through this shot by shot
though they started the 1950s in the i love lucy
bewitch donna reed looking version of reality in
black and white notice the patterns and designs
all over the house that diamond symbol with a dot
in the middle not just all over the house but also
all over vision's clothes what does that remind
you of the mind stone formerly in his forehead
obviously in the trailer footage he's got in his
forehead but that also plays into the idea that
scarlet wishes altering reality to make things
like they used to be when he was alive because
in present day vision is still supposed to be
dead a lot of what's going on in the series is
her processing her grief and slowly trying
to move forward with her life and obviously
because this is just so crazy she can't do that
at the beginning of the series that's why she
creates this alternate reality where he's alive
again and they can live out this life together
but there were a lot of people after avengers
end game that asked why didn't the hulk just snap
vision back when he was bringing everyone back
well obviously now we know the reason is because
they were going to do the Wandavision series
and deal with all the vision stuff during this
you notice when vision turns around the special
effects look like they're periods specific
from the bewitch tv show as if they're actually
living in a reality based on that tv show so when
she uses her power to alter reality you get the
1950s looking version of that red energy effect
you do see some scenes in present day with her
altering the reality with the red energy but
that's when they move to the modern era of tv
shows they talk about how they don't have any
of the common relationship tropes of real couples
like wedding anniversaries a favorite song that
they share that's just because they never had
the chance to do that vision was killed just as
their relationship was starting to get serious
she uses her powers to create rings for them
and then when vision says then they lived happily
ever after that's the whole concept of the series
the lie that she's trying to tell herself like
this is kind of a version of her talking to
herself because vision is supposed to be dead
she can't deal with the trauma of that like you
see her looking all depressed in modern day in
her jammies here sitting on the couch like she
looks like she hasn't been sleeping really well
so she creates a reality where he's alive again
and where she can have this happily ever after
as she says that she always wanted so she's
metaphorically and literally writing her own story
then you get the glitching tv screen effect just
to remind you that not everything works the way
it's supposed to or the way that she wants it to
and it's a big house of m easter egg the cracks in
the alternate reality start to show imperfections
and things start to break down around her slowly
back in the 1950s they dry past the west view sign
obviously west coast avengers it says home
is where you make it because she's literally
making her new home with her reality warping
powers kevin feige was also joking about the
fact that they've been so bad about defining what
her abilities and vision's abilities are so that's
why they're doing a lot of comic book scarlet
witch stuff with her reality warping abilities
but tying that to the power of the infinity stones
like the reality stone then they're still in black
and white but now they've jumped to the 1960s
which is still technically the bewitched era
of tv shows and she talks to him about fitting
in that's just more than trying to keep this
alternate reality from breaking down around them
she's also as you notice super pregnant at this
point most of the scenes of her before she gives
birth to the twins from the comics are still in
the 1970s like the brady bunch looking era then
right after this is the scene of reality warping
around them as they slowly move into the 1970s
and they move into the era of color television
then in the 1970s you start to see their powers
showing more like vision super speeds over to save
her using his powers probably without realizing
that he has powers because he's still a construct
created by scarlet witch you do see him using his
powers later in his full modern comic book costume
but that's probably well after he started to
realize that something's not quite right they kind
of make it seem like scarlet witch when she brings
this version of him back to life she doesn't give
him all of his memories about dying in the events
of avengers infinity war or avengers end game like
she just kind of skips over that part so that he
just remembers all the happy things about their
relationship like as he glitches out here maybe he
starts to slowly remember what actually happened
to him then she finally gives birth we see the
twins like we did in the other footage then the tv
reality glitches again and it seems like they're
either in the 1980s or 1990s wearing the halloween
versions of their classic comic book costumes
this is going to be so funny a lot of people
didn't realize this is meant to be halloween when
this is happening that's why their costumes look
like they're halloween costumes because they
are this scene of agatha harkness coming in
looks like it's happening in the 1980s though just
based on her outfit and her hairdo she glitches
out saying let's take this from the top again
like they're actually living inside a tv show
she calls herself auntie agnes but i believe she's
meant to be a version of agatha harkness from the
comics so they may have just changed her name a
little to modernize it like when she says i've got
a few tricks up my sleeve that's just a reference
to her being a sorceress just like doctor strange
in the comics she's one of scarlet witch's mentors
in the world of magic in the comics this scene of
her repairing the house and the walls with her
power seems like it happens after the scene with
monica rambo because in the other trailer footage
it seems pretty clear that they have some sort of
run-in with scarlet witch eventually throwing her
out of this alternate reality like notice the red
energy around her as she's flying across the frame
they focus on the upside-down cross i believe the
upside-down cross is meant to be a sign of saint
peter which i think is also a bit of a backdoor
reference to her brother pietro maximoff aka
quicksilver there's supposed to be some other
quicksilver references during the show but i
don't know how much quicksilver stuff we'll see
then there's a scene of her back in the cell
from the captain america winter soldier post
credit scene like she's wearing the outfit she
was wearing when she was being experimented on
by baron bond strucker in his hydra cell she and
quicksilver were in the prison cells and he'd been
trying to use the mine stone to see if it had
any effect on them because of the cosmic energy
that it was giving off at the time they had not
fully revealed that there was an infinity stone
inside it the way they edit the footage though
makes it seem like when she touches the mind
stone in front of her is when she enters the
tv-based reality because she's still wearing her
regular street clothes when she enters through
the tv and everything still in black and white
including vision then they have another montage of
scenes cycling through the decades and the present
day outside the bubble reality like in the real
continuity of the mcu like you have randall park
and the fbi trying to save scarlet witch from what
he thinks is some villain but little does he know
she's actually the one doing this to herself
because her mental state is starting to break
down she just can't handle vision being dead the
episodes are starting on january 15th of course
i'll be doing videos for all the episodes there's
only going to be six total but they also have a
couple bonus episodes of another marvel series
that's sort of a prequel to Wandavision called
marvel legends i have no idea what that's going
to look like but it's supposed to be a setup for
Wandavision and it's going to drop the week before
there'll be two episodes on january 8th so i'll do
videos for that stuff too but this is sort of like
the next big thing coming every friday on disney
plus after the mandalorian season 2. the star wars
people also dropped a special mandalorian season 2
bonus episode for everything from season 2 so
i'll do a video for that this weekend as well
there's also obviously the wonder woman
1984 movie on hbo max so there'll be
some videos for that as well bunch of big
stuff coming for the holidays so as long
as you have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see all those videos when i post them
i'll name a giveaway winner when i post my next
marvel video but click here for that brand new
avengers loki trailer for those episodes and
click here for all my mandalorian season 3 and
season 2 episode videos thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe merry christmas!